- All right, y'all
let's close out the hour
with one last bit of
joy for you, hopefully,
this is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
(Kelly laughing)
Get it, Jesse.
Moms, does this sound familiar to you?
I'm bored,
are we there yet?
Ashton got more than me,
Madison stole my headphones,
it's a list goes on and on,
it's enough to make you wanna cry
or trap yourself in a bathroom
and say, "You're still using
the bathroom and you're not"
But that's not me,
that's generally not appropriate
to do in front of the kids, so I hear,
but there's a group of mamas
in Massachusetts letting
out all their frustrations,
all their built up rage and exhaustion
by gathering and releasing
guttural primal screams
away from their little ones,
this is awesome.
(women screaming)
(audience applauding)
It's like the new Ya-Ya
Sisterhood and it's amazing.
These primal scream sessions
are the brainchild of
therapist and mom, Sarah,
who's on the line now,
what's up, Sarah?
(audience applauding)
- Kelly, thank you for having me.
- Oh my God, I'm so happy to talk to you,
so, how did you come up with this?
Were you just angry one day or...
- Very angry, but talking
to my therapy clients
and the community of
moms that I work with,
we were talking about anger for two years,
penned up frustration and rage
and about really talking about
how we had nowhere to put it,
so, I joked with them like,
"We should just all get
in the field and scream."
And they would say back to me,
"Great, let's do it."
So, I did the first one in March of 2021
on a freezing cold Boston night,
and then we did it again
in January of 2022,
and we got together,
we screamed our hearts out,
we cried, we laughed, we
connected with each other,
and really we gave each other permission
to release the anger that
we've been feeling for so long,
and it feels so good,
and Kelly, I highly recommend it,
you should try it.
(audience applauding)
- I'm into it.
I'm definitely into it,
I love this,
so, thank you so much Sarah,
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience applauding)
All right, that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pin Makers of G2,
the go-to pin of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
wanna honor ultimate overachievers,
I can think of no better group than y'all.
So, they're gonna write
you a check for $1,000.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
Now you can buy some snacks
for that get together,
I'm just saying, scream, snacks.
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much Sarah.